welcome everybody back to the h3 podcast
uh number 27 podcast in the usa 5.5 on
wiki feed
uh with us today is cody ko
cody do you have a wiki page i don't
know let's find out i've never looked
yeah can you look well let's look right
now i mean
so do you know what wikipedia is
yeah i know what it is yeah and i gotta
say oh
am i on there
really good rating bro
real no way you have a 4.9 you have a
4.9 out of five yeah but i have what i
have a 5.5
out of five yeah dude
you have a better than perfect yes deep
rating they they somehow
made the website so you can transcend a
perfect score
but there's a lot do you have like three
feet or something
my no my dick is tiny dude
[Laughter]
um
you should really look here there's a
lot of pictures of your feet i will say
that these fetishes are really easy to
uh impress
you know what i mean yeah
yeah like the standards aren't that high
no i don't know i'm really
self-conscious about my feet because
i oh wow oh my god i see that's the one
this is what
you see how much
that's what i'm talking about i took
that picture on tuesday this tuesday and
i was gonna post it to my story and then
i showed it to kelsey and i was like
my feet are in it like i really have
really bad feet and i was like do they
look bad in this picture and she said no
no they look fine and so i posted it and
then every single
dm response i got was either small feet
or disgusting feet every single one
yes like
like 50 of them
every night granted my feet do look
pretty small no they look totally normal
bro i gotta i gotta be here and support
you and i i gotta just ride for you and
tell you that your feet those are 4.9
feet
thank you man you got to feel good about
that rating if you have feet issues
yeah i mean that means a lot good for
you bro well i'm glad to start off on a
happy note here yeah but i do have to
confess something to you
what i brought you here under false
pretense no
what is it
this is actually an intervention
about you being a cyberbully yeah i'm
[Music]
yeah um
actually dude do you have ptsd from
being
blitzed by jake paul that looked really
stressful
um
i think i'm i've gotten i've gotten over
it i think
i've it's you know weather the storm um
you know he's doing his thing i'm doing
my thing i'm sure maybe he still doesn't
like me
i don't i mean i don't know i i'm just i
honestly i want to go back
on jeff's show
i was thinking it'd be it'd be a funny
like sequel if i went back on
because we have like beef now it's fake
beef but it's like real beef at the same
time
oh i haven't been following that so um
well no it's just like from the fact
that he
ambushed me right you know i gotta say
if i was you i'd be a little pissed
because it's like
jake came out hot and heavy but it
wasn't just jake it was like everybody
all the sudden was like yeah you know he
he sometimes if you made a video about
me i'd be gutted and all these guys are
like
it's like a straight up intervention bro
i felt like it was just not cool and i
disagree with them by the way too i
don't think your shit's mean-spirited oh
thank you i appreciate that um
yeah i mean yeah
so i was like you're saying i should
have been pissed at jeff i i would have
been i you're a much better person than
i am apparently i would have been a
little pissed like dude what the [ __ ]
you know well afterwards i was like
because i was telling people and they
were like you should probably be like
pissed at him and i was like because we
had been hiking that day
we went on a nice hike together wow
and then before shooting the show and i
was like we're gonna go on a hike i'm
gonna get a haircut it's gonna be a
great day
and
and so we went on the hike and it was
great and i felt good and they sat down
for the haircut and that happened but i
was just like oh but we did go on a hike
together earlier so i can't be that mad
because it was a nice hike
and then people were like you should
probably be pretty mad and then
i mean like i think that
it turned out kind of funny like the
whole situation for sure turned out
pretty pretty funny and so i wasn't that
mad but then now i'm kind of fake mad
and so i kind of want to go on a show
again and be like don't ambush me again
yeah i wonder if there's someone else he
could have in the closet to ambush you
different people at first he told me he
said we were trying to get lele pawns to
come in and she said yes
and then her manager or someone said no
you shouldn't do that and so she was
like okay fine if only jake had handlers
that smart
yeah
but it was actually it was the greatest
reverse card ever because i remember he
when he posted his video trying to slam
on you dude that's like got a 99
dislike
and uh
and yeah i think it worked out pretty
well for you
but actually are you following the jake
paul news because
like for example it just came out that
he owes two million dollars in federal
taxes is that true i saw that but i
didn't know if it was true or not you
know what i don't know if it's true or
not either it was kind of a tabloidy
paper yeah
a little bit how would you ever know how
much money someone owes to the irs
that's a really good question
uh but i wouldn't be surprised
like does the irs talk to the press yeah
i don't think so like you won't [ __ ]
believe
us
i got a juicy one for you guys
yeah be like hey dude jake paul did you
guys does he owe you guys any money yeah
for that [ __ ] guy
yeah
yeah um
so how are you dude how are you dealing
with everything
you've got a show you've got the uh the
real
the real bros
excuse me
that cough is gonna [ __ ] end me dude
are you all right yeah i'm fine i just
have acid reflux but i feel like it's
ruining our show because i can't stop
coughing
is it because of
is it like
why do you get that is it natural
my buddy has it is because he eats
things that his body doesn't react well
to but he likes he likes them so he
sometimes he eats well i haven't eaten i
intentionally didn't even eat anything
today because i didn't want to inflame
it so i'm on
i'm running on amp you're fat you're
fasting yeah i'm fasting for you
but uh it's not working
is it natural
um i don't know is incest natural
i guess that's a bigger question because
i've got all these
because i mean i don't know is it
because i've got all these neurological
[ __ ] diseases from being like
purebred ashkenazi jew okay and so like
they all are inbred so i don't know is
incest natural that's a question for you
so you're saying it it's from incest
mm-hmm the acid reflux my tourette
syndrome and my g-a-d they call it
which is g-a-d
no not g-a-d it's a
g-g-r-e-m
i think
what is it called when do you guys look
it up i think it's g-e-r-d right
g-e gerd gerd astro esophageal reflux
disease that's what i've got gerd that's
a pretty apt name for that i'm sorry
you got any like diseases
[Laughter]
um i don't have any diseases damn
yeah so [ __ ] lucky
yeah
i know i think i don't know yeah i'm
pretty good as of now but i'm getting
now i'm i'm about to turn 30
and
i just i'm feeling myself physically
breaking down a little bit
but he seems fake that's not a disease i
mean it's just aging yeah i definitely
feel it yeah
um
so you're working on the show
you got your youtube channel you're
touring you've got the podcast how is
kovit hitting you because it seems like
it would affect a lot of the stuff that
you work on regularly
yeah i mean it so for real bros they had
to stop shooting because we needed
basically two these two shots that we
couldn't get once coveted hit and so
that show stopped and then we just
filmed it again like a month ago and so
the episodes will resume in like a week
um
for youtube honestly like staying home
like at the beginning of it staying home
all day every day all i did was write
videos and shoot them
and so i was posting way more frequently
because it was like the only thing that
i could focus on
um and then yeah for the podcast it's
been fine i don't know
mentally like i i we had to postpone the
tour uh till the summer and then till
next summer
so that was you know kind of
you know a bummer
but uh it's it's kind of felt good just
to stay in la
and not go anywhere yeah for a while
i've never like not traveled you know or
like
been on a plane or something
um
for like longer you know two months or
whatever so it's been it's been fine
just staying here
um that's so privileged bro i know
well i mean like just for work too you
know i set you up dude i know i asked
you and then i dunked them
it's just you know even like traveling
for work or whatever it's just i used to
do it all the time and now just staying
in one place yeah [ __ ] i i hate
traveling man i i don't think i could
ever take this podcast on the road just
because
i just the touring is such a such a
schlep dude
yeah
yeah no it's it's pretty rough sometimes
i mean it's a lot of fun yeah it is a
great experience it is yeah
it really is amazing like performing
um
but it weighs on you like there's some
just living on a bus for a month at a
time it's like by the end you're like i
just [ __ ] go home right
like the second one we did i got home
and
this is like you know a month i hadn't
been home in a month and i opened my
front door and
at some point during the month my my toy
like my sewage sewage system backed up
oh [ __ ] so my entire apartment was
filled with like human [ __ ] the whole
thing no like two inches thick
oh was it your [ __ ] or like everyone's
[ __ ]
i mean i think it was a decent amount of
mine yeah because i recognized the smell
a little bit you know you're like oh
what is that
okay
oh that's [ __ ] horrific
yeah sorry
sorry if that's no that's fine
i'm just i'm just that's a horrible way
to come home so then i had to we had to
you know call
servpro to come clean it up and then
they had to redo the floors i had to
throw everything out because everything
it touches is black water so when it
dries it releases bacteria into the air
so then i had to make a giant insurance
claim for like all the stuff it
destroyed so i was living in a hotel for
like a month when i got back from not
being home for a month
sucked
wow dude how much stuff did you lose to
bla by the way black water is a hell of
a name it gets me every time i hear that
like uh
it's not enough that it's covered in
[ __ ] it's black water bro yeah
mm-hmm
so
it's kind of like your apartment burning
down you lost
a lot of stuff
yes because i like it it dripped into my
office so like all the cords i have on
the ground and everything and my
computer is on the ground like
it touched basically everything yeah you
you got to throw that out once it
touches i was
yeah and so it wasn't wasn't a fun
situation
so um
dude we had a little bit of a beef do
you remember about tai lopez
there wasn't a beef there was like hella
beef for a minute dude
it was a beef i like having
beef with people so yeah it was a beef
well
yeah pissed at you yeah i was pissed at
you bro
you're pissing me
dude i was so angry no i'm kidding but
um
what i was gonna ask is that uh you seem
to be a part of this new wave of like
commentary channels is more wholesome
than the traditional sense
is that a conscious decision you make to
kind of
to uh try to be probably less toxic than
what's out there or is it kind of just
naturally what you like to make
um although jake paul would disagree but
yeah exactly am i naturally i think
naturally i'm a cyber bully
at heart
right right right
no i think yeah i think it's just this i
don't know i feel like
maybe when i started and i was trying to
emulate the com like you know i don't
know
i i was maybe a little bit more
mean-spirited
because i really just wanted to make fun
of things and then as you get older it's
like that's not what
it's almost like negative energy is is
actually pretty bad and people don't
really respond to that and it doesn't
really get you that far
um and i really don't want to like tear
things apart and roast things as much as
people think i do it's just
some things are just funny and you just
point out that it's funny but then it's
even funnier to go meet up with that
person
and see what he's really like you know
you ever hear from someone you've made a
video about other than like jake paul
like i wonder about how the uh
the the christian girls against uh
thinking about boys they don't yeah they
don't like us what what is the name of
their group
a girl defined yeah girl defined yeah so
have they responded at all to your
commentary
yeah they they posted
they didn't like respond on youtube but
they posted this thing on their website
that was like
um it was like an ad for their tour or
their book or something like that i
forget what it was but it said it said
with 20 million views on youtube it's
our biggest video to date the only
problem is we didn't make it
and it's in reference to our video
and then i don't know if i forget what
it says afterwards it goes on about how
we suck
they never refer to us though
by name
and so they've definitely like they
don't like us
that's a shame
yeah i mean i feel like you guys feel
like is fair though well i mean dude
it's gotta
like there's no way that either of you
guys could have expected that that video
would have got because that video now
has like over 20 million views yeah and
those girls have just got
i mean they got
[Music]
dude you just jesus christ the [ __ ] out
of them i mean it was crazy
yeah we didn't know it was going to be
that popular yeah like at the time that
was like one of the first ones we did i
think the first that's cringes yeah and
like i don't even think i had a million
subscribers i think they had more
really
i didn't realize they're a big channel
well god bless them
i think maybe i'm not sure but i know
that like their videos like the ones
that we responded to like the how to
dress modestly at the at the pool and
stuff like that when they were like you
know like wear a parka at the pool yeah
in the summer
like those ones had hundreds of
thousands of views because people would
watch them be like this is ridiculous oh
okay so you you guys weren't the first
by the way congratulations on 5 billion
uh subscribers thank you 5 trillion 5
trillion excuse me yeah
how is it i mean your channel's been
growing a lot lately dude how's it uh
how's that feeling man
i mean it feels [ __ ] sick yeah it's
dope right
yeah man like i'm rich now
oh
yeah you got it it's no but it's it's
awesome i mean
i don't i haven't posted as much as i'd
like to in the last couple months but
like at the start of covet i was posting
a lot and everything was going well and
then
and then i started focusing on other
things and it just feels like i want to
do too much sometimes so it's like you
can't yeah i feel that it's hard it's
hard to like i can't prioritize things
you know did you do your fans get angry
when you don't post
people like tweet me and they're like
okay what's up yeah where's videos yeah
where are the videos so what are you
working on how do we justify your
disappearance
okay i'm posting this video tomorrow
that i've been working on for like a
month and a half same sort of thing well
when's this gonna go out this will go up
uh on monday
right there okay yeah so yeah so i can
talk about it because it'll be up
already
it's um i did the same sort of thing i i
met i made one of the that's cringe
episodes we did with this guy named
dharman you've never seen his videos he
does like inspirational
like
uh sketches that he teaches people
lessons
um
and so we did that scrims on him and
then i did a follow-up video on on him
because he gets like
he gets like hundreds of millions of
views on i think overall between youtube
and facebook he's about to hit nine
billion views or something like that
whoa
or four billion like it's in the
billions though it's an absurd amount of
views and he's growing
this into like a legitimate company he's
now
opening like a us i actually i don't
know if i could talk about that
and you've got inside
he does these sketches
and i've made fun of them twice and so
and then he dm'd me and was like oh your
video was really funny and i was
thinking i was like how could i
you know how could i make this more of a
positive thing where where i try to like
figure out what it takes to create one
of these
and so i
dm'd him and i called him and i told him
i was like i want to write one i want to
write one of these sketches see if i can
do it and if you like it you produce it
and i'll even be in it
and i want to see if i can get like tens
of millions of views too
writing like you right
and
and he was like sure let's go for it and
so i did it and then we worked together
on the script and i just learned a ton
of about like why he writes the way he
writes
like
they're all really simple like overly
simple very cliche but it's because he
has a lot of like international people
that don't speak english and a lot of
like six-year-olds their moms will like
make them watch the videos because it
teaches them good lessons
and so it's like a lot of stuff that i
didn't consider and so i learned a lot
by writing this and then i went and shot
it and met with the guy who directs them
edits them and everything and then it
came out on his channel last friday and
so the rest of the video is me like
reacting to the final sketch wow wait
how did i wha what's the name of his
channel
darman
darman
yeah d-h-a-r-m-a-n-n
i gotta see this
worldwide
uh let's see oh wait that's not this is
some random [ __ ] just threw it up oh
good barbecue yeah let's see the kodi
uh
i want to see this inspirational [ __ ]
oh yeah dude we are inspiring the world
1.9 million views
now watch
in a few months i'll be the head chef of
this kitchen
yeah i want to be head chef too but come
on man it's our first day on the job
give it time
i don't have time i want it now
i can't tell which one's the hero jake
you can't cook eggs on high heat
good eggs have to be cooked slowly
otherwise they'll be dry
look
the faster i cook these eggs the more
customers i can feed oh this guy's going
way too fast
i get it for that
and to be done fast
some things require patience so can you
show me the channel uh ian because
go to his face go to his facebook page
oh see yeah this is the kind of guy that
would crush on facebook
facebook's a while look at this
like look at his top most popular
uploads they have like like 14 million
12 million 10 million wow nine million
dude
i'm always i'm always amazed at like uh
the kind of content i find that i just
didn't even know existed there's so many
huge channels and personalities on the
internet yeah same and and yeah that's
that's one of the things too is like
peeling back the or figuring out like
what goes on underneath the surface like
i went to his channel i was like this
guy gets so many views
just assuming it was this one guy making
these videos just for the views and then
i met him and he has like an entire
production team yeah he does his videos
months in advance like he posts one
every two days and he's writing the ones
that he's gonna post in like six months
like it's an entire
uh you know like process that he has
and he really [ __ ] cares about like
teaching people good lessons
he's like a really genuine dude wow
that's so interesting his intentions
were
so going there and going through this
whole process like you might it must
have been
turned all of your assumptions kind of
backwards about the guy yeah 100
100
so we got to go get you to spend a day
with jake paul maybe see if that turns
around your assumptions i wonder if that
would entrench them or turn them around
i would do that yeah i would do that i
just feel like
i don't know i feel like maybe he would
try i don't know
you know i don't know if he would be
into it
yeah i almost fee do you ever almost
feel like shane dawson already did that
right yeah shane did that but he was
trying to prove that he was a sociopath
so i'm not exactly sure he went there
with an open mind
right dan can you turn cody up a little
bit
i almost feel bad for jake sometimes
like
living in the shadow of his brother the
dude just like he just got raided by the
fbi
i mean damn
that's pretty wild and nobody knows why
right yeah i've been providing the guns
or something
it wasn't the guns they went in they
found the guns there and they had to
take them out to secure the perimeter
but uh
part of me
uh
that's why people watch man they like
that
you know i had a kill button last
episode
i don't know why my gerd
has been going crazy
my jewelry
and i had a kill button
usually ela's with me
and um
so i kept killing the butt the mic and
coughing like super [ __ ] loud getting
into it like
yeah because i couldn't i thought nobody
could hear
but ela's sitting right here and it was
worse yeah no her mic wasn't muted so it
was like the worst episode ever people
were just like i can't watch this [ __ ]
ethan is always [ __ ] coughing
yeah people get really mad when we eat
into the mic i've never i've never
minded that sound like hearing someone
chew mm-hmm but it really pisses people
off like really bad i don't believe that
i can't believe you [ __ ] did this
again
like i'm in my car and you guys just
won't stop drinking and eating into the
mic and it's so disrespectful and it's
like i'm just trying to eat some nuts
you know yeah
i have the same reaction i i'm with you
100 i don't really i'm not bothered by
the sound but people get very angry too
when we do that and um
have you stopped are you just saying
[ __ ] it i'm gonna eat
we i stop but you know when i get a
little hungry what are you gonna do
yeah and i need a little you eat away
from the mic
i try i go
yeah but then i you know usually the
last final chew will be a
into the mic you have to give it you
just have to let them know yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
dude i learned this about you that i a
thing i didn't know
not that
i don't know what to do i i'm sorry like
i've been trying everything i can to fix
this issue i thought it was coffee i
stopped drinking coffee i didn't [ __ ]
drink any coffee
okay that's a big sacrifice
uh oh and i was like oh maybe it's
oatmeal i've been eating just plain
[ __ ] oatmeal in the morning
like the most depressing breakfast you
can imagine plant is pretty sad okay cut
out the plain oatmeal here i am with a
glass of water
i'm so i don't know what to do to the
people i mean i'm on medicine
yeah have you tried like pepcid or
something
dude i take sh i take [ __ ]
omaprazol dude i take the serious [ __ ] i
take a pill every morning
i take a bill every morning ian that
reduces
the
amount of fluid in my
[ __ ]
acid in my stomach man
and like
i still ca i still can't stop so i don't
know maybe this business isn't for me
does that mess with your bowel movements
at all
no my bowel movements have been really
clean lately thanks for asking that's
good that's good how was your bowel
movements in general cody i'd like to
know mine have been pretty clean this
week this week i've been eating well i
actually stopped coffee too two weeks
ago why
because it it like i don't know i have i
have weird anxiety but it's like super
physical like hold on
just popped up
like i get really weird physical anxiety
symptoms like i can't feel my limbs and
it's just weird oh wow when i drink
coffee in the morning it used to start i
used to like just kick it off at like 10
a.m i would just feel anxious all day
and i just think about making my heart
rate go up and i don't know my trip my
like you know my threshold now is way
lower for some reason when i'm like
worried about a whole bunch of [ __ ] i
get really anxious and then like it just
anything will kick it off and coffee
every single day i was just feeling like
[ __ ] so i stopped i've been drinking tea
does it help it's
yeah i think so
is it caffeine because it's the caffeine
right i think it's the caffeine yeah you
drinking caffeine-free tea caffeine yeah
it's just like
yeah
yeah uh but about your bowel movements
like pretty good pretty clean
pretty clean yeah yeah so coffee used to
like
you know well it would clean me out
every morning but now you're a little
bit more backed up
now it backed up but it's like more
solid you know that's good this i would
i would change
i would take a rig like a good solid
valve movement over
a regular bowel movement
yeah every time yeah
yeah and when you're wiping uh uh do you
use a wet one do you have a bidet what
what's going on
i um
i'll just take take a poop and then just
jump straight into the shower no i'm
kidding i was ah dude there's people
that do that i know there are a lot of
[ __ ]
my my buddy
my buddy wipes from the front
yeah i do that i'm not kidding you don't
do that you don't swear to god i wipe
from the front
you pick like what do you do
well
it makes sense to me i i cut my balls
and dick
so obviously i don't want to get poop on
it
then just go from the back no because
i've been doing this my whole life it
doesn't i can't go from the back you
don't understand once you i've been
going from the front if i go from the
back it's like i feel like i'm just
leaving [ __ ] everywhere you can't get a
proper clean but you but so you do you
stand when you wipe or do you literally
just lean off to the side and see i
don't
see the leaning seems so ridiculous i
don't have to leave he goes in cupping
your own dick and balls
well i'm not getting [ __ ] on it
i mean leanings like a whole activity i
mean it's like you're getting it's just
like this
that's it okay so say you're in a public
restroom god forbid it happens to all of
us you're gonna risk touching the bull
with your hand to lean over and wipe
your ass like i don't have to touch the
ball when i wipe from the front
oh i see where you're yeah but it's like
your wrist and it's like
yeah i guess that's true i've never
really thought of that before also i
feel like
also do you look at the toilet paper
after you wipe
so just some maybe if it's like the last
one to make sure okay
because i look at every one
and i feel like if i was wiping from the
side i wouldn't be able to look at it
because how are you going to pull out a
shitty you can pull it what do you mean
because you look at it like you finish
and then you look at it when it's
already down i see if you pull out a
shitty square
from the side it's going to get on your
thighs it's going to get on the toilet i
mean no it's not i'm saying it on myself
it's dangerous it seems like a dangerous
maneuver
use baby wipes so this is this is great
i don't but i have before and it really
is something magical you just use
straight dry toilet paper
yeah i do
that's [ __ ] crazy yeah
i feel like america is third world and
as far as wiping is concerned
i mean the fact that you don't use baby
wipes or bidet it means that you have
[ __ ] all over your [ __ ] like there's
no way you could properly clean your
[ __ ]
with just paper oh yeah dude i go i dig
no i dude
you ever went with your [ __ ] there's
red you know
yeah
you what i know that's how you know
you're done wiping is when your [ __ ]
bleed
that's gotta be we really are i remember
we my buddy and i like backpacked
through thailand and
and some places there it's just like a
hose you just spray your [ __ ]
that's crazy it's like a little gun it's
like a little like you know we use for
gardening
it's like one of those
did you get no toilet paper or anything
you just and then you pull your pants up
with just a wet ass your whole ass
and what did you find like an hour later
how did you feel did you feel like
they're like it was all good
kind of itchy i don't know like cause
that means just poop in your butt if
it's itchy well not that i'm talking
about the cheeks like i get this weird
thing where if i go in a pool or
something i think it's because my butt's
like kind of hairy yeah i've got that
when i come out of the pool and i dry
and then i just sit i'm sitting around
i'll get itchy cheeks oh just the cheeks
yeah huh
i i want to know if anyone else gets
that or that maybe that's my disease
yeah itchy cheek syndrome itchy cheeks
yeah
i get that too i know what you're
talking about yeah you do okay oh i've
never felt itchy cheeks before
yeah no it sucks because there's no like
curing it it's just you can't you can't
scratch the itch it's like stays there
oh that sounds horrible well i will tell
you in defense of front wipers uh we've
conducted a survey because i like to say
you know where there's two kinds of
people in this world and they and they
don't even know about each other
i for example assumed everybody wiped
from the front people from the back all
assume people away from the back we
conducted a survey i believe it was like
40
of people wiped from the front so it's
much more of us out there than you
know
wow
40 dude that's actually kind of
unbelievable
we did the survey it was like 40 right
dan uh yeah uh i was shocked i i am a
back wiper myself and uh that's why i
started laughing so hard as soon as you
said of course i wiped from the back
because i was like oh here we go yeah we
had it i mean there was like a whole
month dedicated to
this great debate we have okay gotcha
but you know you can always i don't know
the front thing is weird to me
well i can i get that but it's just the
way it's just who i am as a person and
frankly
the fact that you would even try to
discriminate or to make me feel bad for
who i was born as is is [ __ ] up i
respect it
will you try it
no
you know what's funny bert uh there's
comedian bert crusher who we've had on
the show a couple of times yeah and in
his new comedy special he was talking
about wiping and he made this gesture on
stage like this
yeah like just like like walls
and and and then i immediately damned
him i'm like you're a front wiper bro i
know exactly what that was
and he's like you know 60 of the
audience is like what the [ __ ] would did
he just do
yeah it's awesome
but i do recommend you because i know
you're doing well in life now you got a
lot of stuff going on you're doing good
god bless
get a bidet
okay is it is it really that good i mean
i don't like changing i don't use toilet
paper
so you just it what is it it just
automatically does it you don't got to
touch anything you know well there's a
button on the side
okay you can control the pressure the
aim
although this thing's like
got a.i it always hits the [ __ ]
there's some dude in japan it has
[ __ ] detection
there's one dude in japan who's just
looking at
millions of [ __ ]
programming
see you think it's a one dude yeah it's
just one guy who's [ __ ]
super traumatized
um it's got just got buttons
you can do like oscillation you can do
pulses
uh the seat is warm the water is warm
and it just power washes your [ __ ]
and this sounds like a bougie-ass toilet
and it also has a dryer
oh so like oh see that's what i was
wondering is it sprays and then that's
my problem with the with the gun it was
that it was just my ass would just stay
wet
well but this dries it too yeah it's got
a dryer bro it's like a hand dryer on
your ass although it's like a full like
wash cycle for your ass yeah it's called
a toto there's like these japanese uh
toilets
hotel yeah i'll look into that but
traditionally uh they just have like a a
side like a hand towel that you kind of
just draw your ass off with which is a
little nasty i agree a little bit yeah
but that's what it is man and i think
it's you a real i mean it
changed my life i got to look into that
your your girlfriend is a uh school
teacher right
yeah she teaches preschool is it i find
it bizarre that she's still doing that
because she has a successful youtube
channel she really likes it she likes
she's just a good person yeah she wants
to know but she loves kids
she went to school for it she's really
good at it
and um
yeah she just like genuinely likes
teaching kids
wow and she really like you know she
like all the kids that she teaches and
stuff like that she's like friends with
their parents and
um it's more than just a show up and
teach them their colors it's like you
really like form a bond with the family
and stuff like that and so she loves it
so she and her boss is like one of her
best friends and so
how was uh how was everything during
covet how was it teaching kids over zoom
she had to do it over zoom for a while
and like
they're they're actually it's funny i i
like to have memorized her like routine
because they sing the same songs and
stuff like that every morning and so now
i know all the songs
and um but they're really good on zoom
like one time she was late to a zoom and
she like popped in and they were just
all talking all these like
three-year-olds oh that's so cute
like no parents nothing just like what
what are you what's that doll
and they were just chatting
and they get it they totally get zoom
they understand how to unmute themselves
how to mute themselves which is kind of
scary that's one of it yeah
um but yeah it it it works and now she's
gotta go i think she's gotta go
in again or something like i think
they're opening pretty soon so now they
all have all these masks that
have like a clear plastic thing over
your mouth oh on dude that seems like
fabric around it so it's like [ __ ] it
looks like a mask like it was like a
halloween mask or something like that
but so you can connect with the children
more so they can see you smile and stuff
like that but it just ends up
looking kind of weird are you guys
scared i mean it seems too soon to be
going back to school i i i don't know
yeah
yeah i'm a little bit worried but um
especially if you get coveted or i mean
if any of you get ko kova god forbid
like it [ __ ] up
everything you're working on i'm
assuming you've got this tv show you've
got uh
like like if me and ela each of us get
covered there's just so it affects so
much it's just terrifying
yeah
it is horrifying um
but i mean there's nothing she can do
like
if they need her in the thing she's
gotta go or just not work there i guess
which is like a lot of people's
predicament right now
it's either work or
i don't know work or die work or die
yeah pretty much which sucks but there's
a lot of universities that have opened
and there it seems like they're all
within like two weeks just closing
because there's an outbreak which is
inevitable was it alabama or something
like that had
a shocking rise in cases yeah like 500
in a week or something like that yeah
after opening and i keep hearing the
same stories it's like i went to college
on the first day nobody was social
distancing everybody's partying and
nobody gives a [ __ ] i mean i don't know
how you ask freshmen in college to not
party no
it's like they're gonna do it
it's yeah it's not even a [ __ ] do it
yeah it's not even their fault dude and
even if they show up in mass you get a
couple of uh
natty natty lights in them
oh yeah and then all bets are all
inhibitions yeah wind
it's like my my
my
like one of my good friends i went to
college with him he just dropped off his
little sister there because she's a
freshman now and he was like dude the
the um
restrictions are insane it's like you
can't have more than
two like you know they're they're
tracking everyone coming in and out of
the dorms you can't have more than two
people in your room and all this [ __ ] no
parties if you get caught having a party
you get expelled like right away wow
and but in my mind i'm like this is not
gonna stop them no nothing will stop
them nothing will stop them
dude they will party at
whatever expense
yeah no yeah for sure i mean that's why
you go to college i'm thinking back in
my freshman year
very little studying was done
uh that was low on the priority of why
you go to college yeah
yeah my freshman year was a [ __ ] show
dude looking back i'm all you know i
actually failed out of college one uh on
my
like my third year i had to go uh attend
community college and come back no way
yeah i'm a five-year superstar
wow
he did a victory lap
i'm surprised i made it man how was your
did you make it through call you're
probably a good student right
i was a good so i went to
um i was a good student ninth tenth
grade
and then i went to
something was
something that's called a sports school
because i was a diver
a competitive like springboard diver
and so we were competing a lot and we
would practice twice a day and so i went
to this special school so basically the
school was designed for alpine skiers
because like where i'm from there's a
lot of alpine skiers that go to the
olympics and stuff like that they train
in europe all winter basically so they
need a school that they can do online
that wasn't a thing at that point like
online high school and so this school
was basically designed for these
students where we could do most of our
stuff online and we would only have to
come to
come to class you know when we needed to
like to show up in person and so i just
didn't go like ever
and
so 11th and 12th grade
i just [ __ ] off i didn't do like i i
you know i treated it like it was a joke
and i graduated and i went to duke i got
recruited there so i got in because i
was on the diving team wow and so i went
from not giving a [ __ ] to going to one
of the best schools and
like it was awful i took a class called
the biology of dinosaurs supposedly the
easiest class i do and i got a d yeah
like every athlete was in that class
and they all got a's
and i got a d how do you even study the
b the biology of dinosaurs they're like
you just have to memorize dinosaurs
they're like dudes we don't know they're
just [ __ ] bones yeah yeah no just to
show you pictures it was like a class
for children it was like they showed you
pictures of these old dinosaurs you said
memorize the names of them
and i would and i almost failed that
well hang on did you graduate
yeah i did oh good for you so you made
it
i graduated i got a degree in computer
science so i ended up okay but i that's
always that's always what i wanted to do
is computer science and then halfway
through i almost failed out of that
major and so i read i had to reconsider
whether i even wanted to do it or not
and then i kept going and studying
harder
dude how do you even get into
springboard diving
like as a kid how do you how do you find
a i was just hobby like that i was 10
and my friend
would just hit me up and he was like i'm
going to take this learn to dive class
do you want to join me it's like i don't
know it sounds kind of stupid but
sure because it was like flips sounds
kind of fun chats i was like flip off do
a front flip sure i'll do that
and so i did it once and i was just like
hooked
and then i got competitive he ended up
quitting
and then
yeah i stayed like all my best friends
and everything from from uh from home
like we're all on the diving team we
were like a family you're probably then
you're probably super jacked back then
yeah
hell yeah yeah i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna be humble about that i was yoked
yeah i mean i've seen those guys dude
they're [ __ ]
but you would think like
you just want to be
how do you how do you get yourself
aerodynamic dude in that case like what
is the regiment the exercise regiment to
try to make that little dip right that's
what it's all about is that a little a
little dip yeah
it's called a rip oh it's called a rip i
was super impressed
yeah you're really close
actually um
you just like a lot of lifting a lot of
stretching like you'd be super flexible
right
so like i used to be able to you know
put my i used to be able to sit with
straight legs and put my head in my
knees
um
yeah and it is a lot of repetition
honestly something like diving it's a
lot of muscle memory and just training
your body to do the same thing so that
you can do it under pressure
because that's one of the things is you
train all your hardest dives and then
when you're in a competition
you have to do
you get one shot at each one of your
hardest dives and in between each dive
you have to wait for everyone else to go
so you get cold and then you have to
warm up again and then you have one shot
in front of the judges to do that dive
so it's like training your mind
basically it's like golf
you ever get nauseous waiting i used to
swim in high school and i don't know
there was this phenomenon where we all
got super
nauseous before we played water polo
before a game
yeah
yeah i get that all the time
it was so weird i was just puking all
the time that's how i recall my freshman
year of high school
because i was just i would get so
overwhelmingly nauseous
i once peeped in the pool that actually
did
you puked in the pool well almost i i
was able to puke on the side of the pool
god bless
god bless man it's close man yeah
i i would get really i would get really
nervous before competitions and then i
would you know poop and vomit
stuff like that oh yeah all the good
things yeah at the same time
ever at the same time
no never you know you never know i mean
yeah you side wipers got all kinds of
tricks up your sleeve
[Laughter]
you ever you won any uh awards were you
good at it
i was pretty good i i came
uh i
think i came eighth at olympic trials
wow
that's crazy
and then
and then i qualified for olympic trials
again in 2012 but didn't go because
started a job and stuff like that you're
like [ __ ] deal
but
on the team at duke there were two like
legitimate olympians that meddled and
they were like holy [ __ ]
like unbelievably better than me so that
was pretty cool training with them and
diving with them every day
that's pretty dope
so there is that like distinction
between
like
metal olympians
where you're like wow these guys are
insane
yeah
ian just uh found a video of cody oh
yeah throw that up yes let me see that
little twink hot ass
dip body
[Laughter]
you ever
okay let's see what we got here
which one is he i can't tell that's me
on the right oh you look yeah you look
yolked bro
i wasn't [ __ ] around dude i was
jacked
yeah i mean you're you're serious oh
dude damn
dude your splash was way smaller than
the other homies
i noticed that
that's my homie brandon shout out to
brandon
so this is this was nationals
and in winnipeg ontario winnipeg ontario
when they look at that posture farting
oh
dude
you are really good at that
and we won this but because we were the
only people that competed in
synchronized
oh you won there was no competition
there was nobody we were the only ones
we would get out dry off and then go up
and do the next manitoba
but you guys are about canadian so
so how is this working you guys are on a
team you're synchronizing yeah yeah and
you got the gold
we got the gold one out of one
yep
yeah we killed it
smashed it i'm just is this is this
something
that was a bad one wait is this on
repeat am i watching the same thing no
it's okay it's still going
see there that was the score at the end
it was just our names that's awesome
right
you ever like uh
is it dangerous i feel like i've seen a
lot of people get injured like that if
you're too close to the dive board knock
your head on it and stuff like that yeah
i've seen some pretty gnarly [ __ ] like
i've seen tons of people hit their heads
on the boards their hands their fingers
i saw one girl
uh one time she was on my team she did
she was on 10 meters like the highest
one and she was doing front three and a
half so like
front three flips to a dive and she like
slipped because like when you're in the
air
you like keep track of where you are but
she slipped out of her like tuck and so
as soon as you do that you like lose
where you are and so she face planted in
the water and her her hairline was
bleeding oh and her like her eyelid like
it was messed up
she had a concussion oh my goodness that
poor was out for a while that's scary
that you could actually just get that
injured hit in the water
yeah it's it's brutal
i gotta tell you i think i'm too much of
a [ __ ] to even do what you did there i
i'm terrified to do any of that [ __ ]
i'll get used to it
though you work up to it and then once
you do it enough it's just normal
but it's like it is all muscle memory so
as soon as you stop for like when i
stopped it was like two weeks later i
used to be able to do like a backflip on
the ground and stuff like that
two three weeks later of not doing that
stuff and this is your body just forgets
because
like your intuition is to not land on
your head because your body's trying to
protect your head uh and so you gotta
train yourself not to do that and then
if you don't do it for a while it's just
you just forget how so you can't do that
kind of stuff anymore no oh man no way
yeah
dude
this surprised me you made that app i'd
cap that
yep
huge app
on the app store back in the day was it
like 2012 somewhere somewhere around
that yeah 2012
it was a m you put an image up and then
you you kind of programmed this app
where it puts a caption on it
yeah
you got like four million downloads in
like four months
yeah it was pretty wild and then you
sold it
yeah
are you excited
no no
it sounds like one of those big ass
sales
i sold it for like i think
i don't even know if i can say this but
i think it was like a hundred grand but
50 grand cash 50 grand stock in this
company that
that i sold it to because i worked for
them for two years afterwards oh
and they were a startup they were like
12 people or something i see and
that's how i got a job out of college
because
i was diving so much and i had
competitions and stuff all my friends
were like already interviewing mm-hmm
because they do you know at schools they
do like the career fair so you meet the
companies and then they go out
you know they they interview you out and
wherever they are and i just couldn't do
that [ __ ] because i had i was diving and
so i was had no job lined up for after
college i wanted to be in the states but
i needed a job because i can't just be
here i need a visa
and
so i wrote this app just like by chance
because i wanted to teach myself how to
make iphone stuff
that's how i did it
because i knew that was like more of
like a marketable skill if i could like
everyone was doing apps at that time so
i was like if i can write an app then
someone's going to hire me to write
their app
and so i wrote that app as like a
project and it went like super viral
and this company that i sold it to did
like a mobile ad sdk so like they were
the technology that when you're playing
a game and an ad for another game popped
up
that was their technology
and so they would plug that into like a
ton of different apps they needed a lot
of traffic that's like
how an you know mobile ad network would
succeed and so with my app they were
like we just buy this app that has the
most amount of traffic
and pump this these ads in it basically
and so my first job was for them was
writing another one called i'd cap that
two
and actually no my first job for them
was making the paid version because it
was a free app that i made they bought
it i moved to palo alto and wrote the
paid version
and right away we released it and it
made like 200 grand oh that's [ __ ]
[ __ ] god yeah i could have just done
that on my own yeah
but that's pretty s dude i have to tell
you i think you know we started this
conversation by talking about this guy
who makes these motivational videos it
sounds like you've you've succeeded at
everything you've done cody you should
be making motivational videos what what
are you doing dude
you think i should just should i just go
to like vegas and just give talks i
would tell tell me what the [ __ ] do i
need what am i doing wrong bro
motivational speeches yeah no you're
killing it too well but i feel like i
feel like i could use some motivating
so you want me to give you advice yeah
what's your
please
um my advice is you gotta it all starts
when you wipe from the side
oh no i can't go i can't walk that path
that's where it all starts man i can't
walk that path i'm telling you once you
do that it's enlightenment
you know be cool i'd like to see like a
list of most successful front wipers
that'd be [ __ ] cool as well if forbes
should do that richard obama's what if
like i bet obama might be a front wiper
you don't know
like who knows man
you never know
yeah i bet he yeah i don't know
i would like to see that honestly i
really would i i do feel like generally
i don't know if you know who bert
christie is but he's like a total
[ __ ] slob
uh i feel like only slobs and [ __ ]
losers wipe from the front
well which which have you guys wiped
from the front i know one of you guys
admit to it ian was the i do yeah oh
okay i mean i'll take ian he seems
pretty i mean
it's all about the the if you hook you
hook in
and you don't deal with any problems
it's the angle yeah so you don't cup
your own [ __ ] you know you kind of go
around no see that's risky sorry dude
mine did so i gotta make sure it's out
of the way
my dick
oh i guess i just put through i throw it
over my thigh
yeah that's what i usually do i just
toss it over my shoulder
ethan actually converted me to the
wiping he does whoa
i didn't we talked about this zach
you're such a simp jesus
we talked about this like a year ago no
no no i remember a comment of somebody
being like yo i started wiping from the
front and it changed my life
i didn't know you got converted zach
yeah of course you gotta lift the balls
and go man so tell cody what the
benefits of wiping from the front
because he's a hey oh my god so you went
from you went from back to front
yeah yeah yeah
tell them why tell them give them it's
easier
you know it's i think it's cleaner to
tell you the truth i get a good clean
dude yeah you know i like to look in
your butt
i like to look what's on uh the baby
wipe sometimes
that's the big difference between the
front and side is the look
because i look at every wipe why do you
look at every single one
well the first one is has the most
you data want to get rid of the first
one
like i mean there's there's a few
there's a couple reasons to look at your
wipes one is to
glean information and the other one is
to make sure you're clean so i feel like
you're doing the second part but not
doing the first part
i see
does that make sense do you look at your
poop in the toilet
maybe in the to like when i'm done i'd
stand up and look yeah
or down i'll catch a glance yeah i'm
curious
i'll sneak up oh i mean there's an
important thing
i'm serious there's you want to know you
want to know if if that your poop looks
healthy that's true actually yeah it's
important uh
to know that kind of stuff yeah and if
you remember
there was a big faction of like stand
wipers
too yeah yeah yeah those people are
long gone well your cheeks get pushed
together so i just don't understand how
you could possibly get an adequate wipe
stand yeah that seems like it would do a
weird like
you know like a rorschach painting or
whatever it's called right
but you know um
sometimes you sometimes like you're out
of toilet paper and you have to stand
and reach and i feel like i'm always
smushing my [ __ ] together when i have to
stand up and get toilet paper so the
fact that you would willingly stand
shocked yeah it doesn't make that
doesn't make any sense any sense no it
doesn't
i put my legs up like this
i sit i lean back on the toilet and i
put my legs like this dude you're pretty
flexible still i'll say
no dude i'm not nothing compared to what
i used to be
um i used to be limber hmm
[Music]
[Laughter]
dude how do you prepare for your videos
because when i watch them it has a
certain quality
uh
it looks effortless but how much
preparation goes into them
it kind of depends on which which ones
like
uh the that's cringes with with me and
noel we would just sit down and just do
them like all of them are just like
nothing planned because i think
one shot net multiple shots
multiple shots like takes i guess no it
would just be like
it would just we just do it for an hour
just run through the video and make as
many jokes as possible maybe if we like
talked over each other we'd be like all
right let's take that again
um if like someone said something funny
but those are totally off the cuff and
then for like most of mine that i do by
myself i'll like write them lightly
and then i'll leave but it's kind of
changed now now i'll leave a lot of room
for
[ __ ] around and because i like when i
watch my own videos and they don't seem
scripted
and so i'll leave a lot of room for like
me just messing around does it get
frustrating though when you're like when
you leave that space and then you feel
like on the spot you're having a hard
time filling it
what do you mean like maybe sometimes
if you leave open space and you're like
i'm gonna make some jokes here when you
oh yeah and you're like oh this isn't
funny this isn't working
yeah you know it's also like it's
sometimes i i'll feel a lot bit like if
i feel on that's never a problem if i'm
filming i'm like the energy is great and
i love what i'm
talking about then i never really run to
run it into that issue it's kind of like
when i don't feel that great
or you know the thing that i'm watching
isn't that funny or whatever then i'm
feels like i'm pulling teeth sometimes
it is kind of a bad feeling do bail and
i'll see the edited version and i'll uh
do i bail on it yeah have you ever bail
on a video like a couple times yes when
i just know it's not gonna be funny at
all and i'm like this is pointless i'm
just doing this to put up a video
do you find do you get depressed by that
are you just able to move on
i get depressed when i don't have like
ideas and i don't feel funny
like if i'm not posting for a while i'm
like i should be but i just i don't feel
inspired and then i go through other
moments where i have too many ideas i
kind of hate that i wish i was more
consistent like how the [ __ ] does
pewdiepie do it every single day it's
disturbing every day he's got a new
video and it's
fresh and he's totally
seems sane
it's very disturbing to me that he's
able to do seven videos
a week sometimes more it seems like yeah
it's it's he's got a super power i mean
there's nobody else that can do what he
does
it's it's ridiculous
but i i my problem was like
i think the the biggest reason i stopped
making videos
is that i was having trouble finding
good content right to to
talk about yeah and then i would find
one or you could you kind of get
desperate so i would find one and be
like oh this is good
and then when i would get down to record
i'd be like oh this isn't good this
isn't funny yeah this is awful and it
was just this horrible cycle of like
no i just felt like nothing you get into
this pits where it's just like i don't
know i felt like i would get into a rut
where it's like nothing works for so
long that i just i just don't even want
to do it anymore
yeah yeah no i i
i agree i mean it's funny people will
ask us like where do another that's
cringe do you know that's cringe because
we haven't done one for like a year now
and i think that
we did like the ones that we were doing
when we before we stopped doing them
like right before we stopped they were
good but they weren't as good as the
ones that people really love like the
met like the girl defined one of the
maddie smokes one and like reflecting
back i feel like we got really really
lucky with those videos
because we're only as good as the video
is you know because you watch that video
alone it's already hilarious
and then all we're doing is you know
making as many jokes as we can
and like we hit something special but
there just isn't a lot of media like
that right yeah it's it's
right
i feel the same way about some of my
early videos like i would sit down
and react to them
off the cuff with no planning
yeah and it was like you know i mean you
can't find pranks in the hood anymore
that kind of gold just does isn't on the
internet yeah yeah pranks in the [ __ ]
hood bro yeah
there's a lot of it on tick tock but
right
but even because you can do that on tick
tock now you can take the video and
react to it on tick tock and that's its
own little ecosystem
it's not the same
what do you make of tick tock you're
you're from vine
do you think tick tock has what it takes
to succeed where vine
failed
yeah
yeah that's a phenomenal i think if
trump like lets it stay it's going to be
around for a long ass time i feel like
what is it about this they're behemoth
like yeah they do no matter they will
not fail like they
they poured billions of dollars already
into just
you know being recognized as
uh like you know at the beginning when
it was musically and then it was first
tick tock like they were pouring money
into marketing it just to like shoehorn
it into
uh pop culture
and now they did that they spent the
money they made it this big ass thing
and they won't let it fail i feel like
it's already the biggest social media
app in the world i think right now
dude i gotta get on in the states for
sure to figure it out yeah no it's it's
it's ridiculous
and um
actually um
a b who's with us his girlfriend or his
wife sorry who's on tick tock uh they
started rolling out this this program
where people are getting paid on tick
tock now yeah me too i just made three
bucks three [ __ ] bucks yeah i just
looked right how are the rates
look at this [ __ ]
yeah you're doing pretty good on
tick-tock
i gotta get on till talk bro i'm that's
i'm doing tick-tock that's it let me see
that [ __ ] let it focus
i i if i can't see it i don't believe it
okay hold on let me turn on the
brightness let's see if that
come on baby sorry dude i don't believe
it
oh
three sec wait really
baby wait hold on you didn't tell me
375.
3.75 yep so what's the rate how many
views because you get a lot of views it
doesn't seem like a very good rate
it doesn't tell me how many views i got
for that day it just tells me how much
money i made on the 24th of august but i
think the cpms are really low i think
well but yeah what i heard they did is
they just put up like a billion dollars
of their own money
yeah because it's not they're not paying
out but i guess they're working on some
kind of ad rev share right now which
that's what i mean is that
like you know when vine was kind of
struggling and people were leaving and
stuff
they were like well there's nothing we
can do we can't pay them tick tock's
like oh no we just paid them
yeah we'll pay him oh
oh you guys are leaving here's three
billion dollars yeah
and so so there's no reason why anyone
wouldn't do it right now like
so the so what happened with vine is
that they're just like dude we're
putting all this effort in and we're not
we're just not making a living and and
ultimately people started leaving vine
is that what happened
yeah just people started not using it
like even the
audience
it just started i think i honestly i
think a big part of it was instagram
video i think that stole a lot of
traffic away from vine and then it
didn't seem like people were using it i
feel like it was kind of a
self-fulfilling thing where it just
seemed dead
so it's kind of it feels kind of like
snapchat to me right now if it feels
dead like no one uses it i don't know
yeah that's saying he does but
um yeah
yeah it was kind of weird i would notice
that my videos just get less views and
less comments and it just feels like huh
people just weren't using people weren't
talking about it i didn't see them on
twitter as much and so twitter
eventually was like this is just like a
resource suck and it's
and it's not worth it so they shut it
down
so
you're pretty active on tick tock do you
like the platform
i'm not that i don't post that much
because i don't know i don't know what
to post i don't know even how i'm bad at
it i'm just people like someone tweeted
me there oh a while ago they were like
man it's such a shame that cody's tick
tocks are cringy
i was like [ __ ] why would you do well
come on
they are kind of though when i watch
them i'm like damn dude but tick tocks
how
by the very nature of what tick tock is
it's kind of inherently cringy
right it's like hard to even make
content that isn't a little bit cringy
yeah i mean i there's a lot of good [ __ ]
on there now like there's a lot of stuff
that me and kelsey genuinely
laugh at but i just don't know how to
make it
yeah
huh i gotta use my kid in some way i
gotta exploit my son i think
yeah that would definitely work
i got to exploit my son more
yeah
yeah you have a yeah you have a baby
he's cute you should be using that child
he's just starting to talk
i mean i'm i'm leaving a lot of money on
the
you guys could be the new ace family
yeah
the gerd family
[Laughter]
oh man
yeah i gotta get a tick i'm just curiou
because it's like i feel so out of the
loop i just i don't want to ever feel
like this old out of touch [ __ ] was like
oh but you know what it's so there's
this crazy phenomenon i've noticed on
tick tock is that there's a lot of old
people on there
making crazy ass old people tick tocks
and i and i can't figure it out so i
guess it can't be that hard no yeah like
senior citizens you're talking about
yeah were they like keeping out the
background and they're doing karaoke
it's awesome yep i just saw one
yesterday that like went viral that was
really funny
we have in
common uh
we talk about other youtubers me and you
and i know that you kind of like for
example jstation is is one that you
focused a lot on
and my question for you is who is like
your favorite kind of classic meme
youtuber
when i say that i mean like j station
soflo
you know
yeah ethan bradberry
favorite meme
um
just like a living meme you know yeah i
mean
i think maddie smokes was pretty good
because we we he's just a funny kid man
we did that video and then
we we we were touring in vancouver where
he's from
and he came out
to the show because we wanted to bring
him on stage and surprise the audience
that he was there
and
so we were like okay you gotta come to
the back and you gotta you know we'll
sneak you in so nobody sees you
and so he finally comes to the green
room like a little bit late and we're
like where were you at and he was like
oh i was just taking pictures outside
with everyone
once
with the line to get in the venue he
just was walking by the line it was just
taking pictures of that
and we're like you [ __ ] you ruined it
um
like he's just hilarious and his friend
his friend his name is liam and by the
time you're in the green room the kid
the kid's like
18 he had drank like four beers which is
ripping this vape thing that he had like
just ripping it
and was doing tricks and everything like
he just was in it was like we were
watching a live video you know yeah
it was hilarious and he's just funny
like he's a funny funny dude i used to
play fortnite with him all the time oh
uh that's very wholesome yeah i love
when the when the meme
like for example with ethan bradbury
we're like dogs now dude
are you yeah dude he's he's my homie
like that guy would kill someone for me
i'm sure of it
wait i saw i saw
you played like a ban like a video that
he did or something
oh the forbidden one he's talking about
yeah it was like he like
did something about covet or yeah we we
were like because i love ethan's whole
vibe and i was like dude do a man on the
street for me this was like right when
kovitz started to hit
and i was like go ask people in new york
about kovit
and then a couple days later he sends me
this video of him like
he's like hey what do you think about
covet
i have it and [ __ ] like that and i was
like ethan not only can i not show this
you'll get arrested if i show this
like you will literally get arrested
oh my god so he took it as like i should
go do a prank video
i think that's just the language that
they speak right
you know i was like just go ask people
about kovid because i think you're
everything you do is interesting
and oh my god
that's oh that's horrible yeah no it was
horrible i was horrified
i mean i didn't even show it i just
played the audio because um
because i don't want him to get arrested
i mean i i don't know what to say i mean
but but the only thing i can say in his
defense is that it was at the new york
wasn't even shut down
yeah yeah so it was like in the early
days
serious it was yeah people were getting
a little spooked yeah
uh yeah so yeah i'm trying to think of
who else i don't um
i mean maddie smokes was just the
ultimate i feel like
because he was such a meme yeah
how was your time with tai lopez you we
it was funny because i don't know what
it was like
tai lopez
i guess he was trying to do some pr or
something he's kind of off the radar now
poor tai
i know it's so funny like last week i
was sitting there i was like i wonder
just randomly i wonder what the [ __ ] is
up with tai lopez
and i go to his instagram and he said
that himself he's like yeah you know
i've been off social media for the year
but now i'm buying all these companies
just what i i just bought pier one
imports yeah i read that what the [ __ ]
he bought like four literally bought
people on import brick and mortar
franchises he's a scammer right like
he's gonna flip them and i
i don't know i still don't really weird
going on there i still have no idea but
say that again what was that
knowledge oh knowledge right yeah i
couldn't tell if that was keemstar or
my garage yeah
[Laughter]
i'm glad you have that queued up
any anything else zack you wanna hit us
with
no knowledge yeah
yeah how was your time with him because
mine was super weird mine was like super
weird because he brought lawyers to mine
did he do that to you yeah he did yeah
he brought that dude
the same guy was there yeah weird like i
feel like he's not actually a lawyer
oh i got mad lawyer vibes from him
you got lawyer vibes from that dude yeah
i i got like like what's the lawyer from
breaking bad
he like a fixer
yeah goodman assault saul goodman oh
like a doctor that's the lives i got
like well the entrance help me break the
law
yeah and in truth i don't think any like
honest-to-god reputable lawyer would be
like yeah sure i'll come to your house
and eavesdrop on some youtuber at 9pm
yeah
it was really yeah it was but he lied he
lied to me about it he was like oh sorry
i'm just having a meeting right now
i was like why is this guy five feet
behind us all the time yeah he followed
you right he followed us too so he
listened to everything we said
what the [ __ ]
i so i looked up
i i looked up his house his house that
we went to the bet you went to you went
to the same one right we had koi pond
and everything
so
koi pong i don't know you walk right you
walk in there's like a huge gravel
entrance and then there's like a huge
courtyard in the middle with a long
swimming pool and then the back there's
a gym
yes yes yes yeah yeah yeah in the front
there's a co like when as soon as you go
in the front door there's like a koi
pond in the middle of the oh you're
right or whatever yeah yeah um right i
saw that on zillow i think last week or
the week before it's 27 million dollars
that house
it's for sale right now i gotta tell you
i figured that was a more expensive
house that house was fun 27 million i
mean it's in like the most expensive
neighborhood in beverly hills
yeah
i mean it it's also like not it's like
nine bed 13 bath or something like that
it's wild
but i mean i feel like that's pretty
expensive 27 million bucks yeah that's
up that is up there for some reason i
thought it was more i don't know why i
was very impressed by that house it's a
it's like a compound yeah it's a
compound like the pool and then the gym
in the back upstairs there's like a dojo
mm-hmm
it's like a fighting mask like that
yeah but it was i mean i saw him like we
did that video and then like two months
later i was walking through the venice
canals and there's this like house there
that has this giant open
like
area downstairs like at ground level and
i looked in there was someone like
teaching like a court like he had a
giant you know like piece of piece of
paper thing yeah and then he was like
writing on it i was like is someone
teaching a course in there and he was
like live streaming himself and i looked
over at tai lopez and he was like cody
oh my god and we just exchanged hellos
and then left and i was like that was
bizarre he's still doing his thing with
the board and everything yeah renting
houses and like renting airbnbs in
venice and doing that and then leaving
do you find it so bizarre the thing he
does with models where he like
he always has models around and he pays
people on twitter to guess their
ethnicity do you follow that
he always does this thing he goes if you
can guess her ethnicity i'll give you a
hundred bucks
that's bizarre yeah i always found that
really weird
anyway listen i want to
um in closing
kind of
i have some videos that are classics
here that that i'm hoping you haven't
seen
okay and i want to get your take
my first favorite one here is the uh
it's just a dude taking a poop in a in a
bathroom stall
and something happens
okay
and uh this is this is probably my
favorite video
so
i think ian's gonna cue it up here for
us there it is
world star you know it's good
you feel that tension
the suspense is killing me
i love this [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
it's awesome
what
so
so here's the question i always ask
okay
[Music]
by the way that that's obviously like
not the first time that's happened
my guy was like smiling he was like
smirking
i guess he i guess he's got some fetish
for smelling poo or or maybe just wanted
to
i mean
but who says sorry just tell me who says
sorry is it the guy pooping or the guy
on the floor
he's like what
they were calling your whole time right
there
he was like he kind of did a little
laugh and he smirked a little bit i love
him he wants to be caught he's like yeah
i'm down here and then the guys are
recording i'm recording you and he's
like oh [ __ ] okay sorry yeah don't show
my face
sorry
so wait wait sorry i'm so sorry because
i feel like the guy recording says sorry
and i think that's hilarious
he's like sorry i stopped you
then yeah i didn't mean to
invade your privacy by filming you he's
like what are you doing here he's like
huh
uh ian hi hit me with the the sorry
moment because i still have not resolved
who says sorry it's definitely the guy
on the floor
no it's not
the whole time um racial oh
sorry
i swear it's the guy [ __ ] says sorry
i don't yeah i don't see the
the the the peeking guy's mouth and it
sounds like the guy on the toilet he
says sorry
it's awesome sorry
sorry
maybe it is
he's like sorry i fooled your plan i
think it was just so awkward you know
what to say like sorry bro sorry a
little poop smeller not today
didn't mean to [ __ ] up your day but
sorry dog it's just a little
uncomfortable for me
it's kind of a compliment really isn't
it that somebody's willing to
sneak under the stall to smell your poop
yeah i guess he's like you have
chick-fil-a today hmm
you frown or you've wiped yeah
from the side yeah what if you just yeah
what if he's just doing research for the
front wipers hey leave your first swipe
on the uh floor for me would you
yeah
okay um
the next one
that was a good video right yeah that
was great yeah some of my favorites
thank you for saying that
uh garth brooks facebook have you seen
that
no oh yes yes yes yes yes yes
go ahead ian so let me give you some uh
pretense here oh my god so garth brooks
back in the day i guess facebook was
relatively new he posted on his facebook
page
one video
and then he disappeared this was the one
video okay yeah go ahead
well i guess it's official we're now on
facebook i really wasn't sure about this
at the start but then a friend of mine
said something that just made all kinds
of sense
she said think of it more as a
conversation
i like that
but i'm already finding out on my own so
it's wiping the walls out between you
and me and i really like that
it allows us into each other's worlds or
i guess in my case
the hotel room
when i think about things i want to post
i want to post cool stuff slick stuff
neat stuff
but most stuff i'm gonna post is gonna
be raw stuff like this
this is just who i am
so if this is truly a conversation
then i say let the conversation begin oh
my god it feels like a matthew
mcconaughey video dude yes
oh my god he has the same cadence of
speaking it i felt like i was watching
an audition tape like i feel like he's
done that 50 times in the mirror exactly
cool stuff needs to have slick stuff
if it's tearing down the walls between
me and you i say let the conversation
begin
and then he just never posted again i
like that no he bounced
that's [ __ ] awesome yeah
um it's the it's one of the best videos
ever because it's supposed to be so
candid but it's all obviously scripted
so script and uh
i like that i don't really like that
pretty like conversation i like that
actually i think garth is one of my
favorite memes because gerd brooks gerd
i call him garf g-a-r-f
garf-bros
uh yeah he's alleged
i really like that
little absolute legend move not posting
ever again
[Laughter]
just being like i'm gonna post not only
am i gonna post slick stuff i'm going to
post neat stuff but mostly it's going to
be raw stuff but actually it's going to
be nothing yeah
well i think he got just totally memed
on into oblivion
because people are like garf this what
is this
have you seen matt mcconaughey's like
recent videos oh yeah i'm taking [ __ ]
about his book green light
well we've been taught we've been
following oh don't get me started on
that
it's so funny you've been doing a lot of
research on that right you have the
green light i've been compiling all of
his quotes from instagram for like nine
months do you have anything so we got to
us
yeah i've got them in like a folder
shoot it's like
i pre-ordered it look because it
hard copy version read it cover to cover
see the ones that i found
this one i i pondered this for so long
it was this quote it says you'd better
be different not sorry
huh
and i'm like really makes you think
doesn't you'd better be different
comma
not sorry
i think he's saying you better be
different not
sorry
or here's another one uh do it because
you want to not because they don't
wow
wait wait that's that one's [ __ ] my
brain up do it because they it's almost
like he's just trying to put [ __ ]
together that makes as little sense as
possible
do it because you want to
not because they don't i mean what could
that possibly apply to your parents like
if you like porn and trying to piss your
parents off like if you do porn i can't
think of anything else
they don't want don't do it because they
don't want you to do it
i know they don't want they don't want
to do it
they don't want to do it they'll be like
they don't want to
i'm i shouldn't find motivation
in like i shouldn't i shouldn't want to
succeed because they don't want to
succeed i should want to consider
because i just want to succeed that
doesn't make sense i don't think i've
ever been motivated by that in my life i
don't think so that's the problem
matthew's got an interesting brain
they're just so many go ahead and i'm
enjoying cool give me throw me a couple
get them early so you don't have to get
them often
get them early
so you don't have to get them often
get them
go and get them
get what is what could that what does
that mean better get them because i get
them early
so you don't have to get them often
but maybe maybe
you know
because you could probably want to get
them multiple times right
what is he getting
i don't see the the the i don't see how
the uh
frequency of getting them
affects the
the punctuality of it what stage you
adopt it yeah it doesn't seem to be a
relation there
get them early before it's gone
yeah maybe to me there's yeah
i don't know maybe it's like a
like uh yeah like you go to trader joe's
in the morning and they have more [ __ ]
get it early
at least they don't have to get it off
he's talking about like a big-ass bag of
but here's the thing usually things you
don't need to get often you don't need
to get early
like yeah you're like i'm gonna get this
huge bag of popcorn you've seen you know
those huge bags it's like 50 pounds but
yeah but those people are not rushing to
get that stuff that's true so yeah so
it's more like get it
the early part
get them early so that you don't have to
get it later that's what it should have
been get it early so you don't have to
get it later which is kind of explained
in the first part though isn't that what
getting it really does yes yeah i guess
it's kind of yeah and come let's let's
uh
this is my favorite one i think yeah
this one's a real
real mind
mind bender
uh when did guilt by deed turn into
guilt by association turn into guilt by
conversation whoa
[Laughter]
can you say it again
when did guilt by deed is just doing
something
when did you just murdering someone
turn into guilt by association turn into
guilt by conversation so he's saying so
he's saying
so saying somebody kills someone that's
a guilt by a deed literal act of crime
turn into guilt by association so say
let's say ian you killed someone and i
know you that's guilt by association so
they say well [ __ ] you turn into guilt
by conversation
i think that's just a way of his him
commenting on like cancel culture yeah
yeah but
but he did it very elegantly
elegantly
very very
round about in code you seen his lincoln
commercials i love that [ __ ]
i think i think so he goes he has one
where he goes uh
he just goes he literally this is his
only line he goes yeah
i swear to god he just goes yeah
i swear that's it that's awesome can you
try to find that ian
just just this gird acting he goes
yeah yeah
i like i actually like matthew though
he's a good actor
he he like this one you've seen the long
branch in the pork cracklin video
say again he's like you ever seen that
you've seen the video where he drinks
some long branch and he eats a pork
cracklin no she'll pop that up again i
don't even know what you'd search to
find it he's like in his hotel room
and he's like can't sleep
just winding down with a glass of long
branch whiskey and a pork crackling
i think he also long branch i think is
his company right oh it's just a promo
you see ryan reynolds sold his gin
company
for 600 million [ __ ] is with ryan
reynolds and now
600 million dollars didn't george
clooney pull that too he sold his [ __ ]
for like a billion yeah
the same company to the same company
who's buying all these [ __ ] liquor
companies for a billion dollars some
behemoth
i gotta start distilling vodka or some
[ __ ] yeah
the guy that made i just was reading
about the guy that made white claw
he's a beverage connoisseur he's been
around he made mike's hard lemonade that
was his first drink
and now he's worth like multiple
billions of dollars
you know um
you may i may uh teach you something
here today we've debated this at great
length and decided i was correct about
all vodka being literally the same right
dan did we decide i was correct
well i mean i don't know if we decided
it we found some research that seemed to
indicate so all vodka
is
the same taste
and is the same
alcohol so what about like the distill
or whatever
it's the same
but i swear when i drink gray goose it
tastes better
yeah but like so here's what i would
tell you to do try this experiment next
time you're drinking a nice vodka pour
out the gray goose
okay take that aside for yourself
get the shittiest vodka you can find get
that [ __ ] with the top comes off did i
do this right now i'm already pretty
drunk so yeah
yeah whenever you're ready put in the
shitty vodka into the grey goose bottle
and see if anybody says anything
okay
i'll do that that's pretty sight is that
a cycle because i used to drink
aristocrat vodka in college remember
that stuff aristocrat can you ever drink
that no
yeah
plastic handle cost like two dollars of
course it would be the cheapest [ __ ]
with the name like that and it's
horrendous
it's like hand sanitizer yeah it really
tastes different right it does yeah yeah
ian do you have anything for us to watch
or should i move on to mobilitymary
i couldn't find the um commercial you
were talking about but
i think one that's kind of funny
oh you didn't find that
this one's pretty good yeah this is a
classic what's that wait was that i like
that that wasn't actually that was garth
that was the sound right okay that was
good
i like that
dude
i like that brands are just giving up
they're like [ __ ] it dude this we just
gotta like
like have you seen this johnny depp uh
uh perfume commercial no
you know what i'm talking about ian
i'll look for it
these brands have just given up they're
like dude i don't even know how to
market this [ __ ] anymore it's a lincoln
like how do we convince people to buy a
lincoln
uh i was just imagining the bull
charging the car and it getting like
totally [ __ ] up
uh is this yeah this is it
are we gonna get claimed for this [ __ ]
probably not
[Music]
[Music]
good luck ethan because you're gonna
[ __ ] need it
garbage it's the same [ __ ]
yeah it's the [ __ ]
exact same yeah
that's the same ball he's in every
commercial what am i looking for
[Music]
something i can't see
i can feel it
yeah it's it's perfume bro he's crying
yeah
somebody's gotta do a commercial like
that but it's just for the animal like
at the end it's just like buffalo
buffalo meat paid for by the dairy
farmers of america did i just hear zach
defend that commercial you said that was
badass
uh yeah i think that's a badass
commercial so does it make you want to
buy the sauvage
uh
maybe
oh zach come on man
yeah i love johnny depp like i think
he's a [ __ ] badass how do you how do
you feel about the amber turd situation
[ __ ] i don't even know what to think of
that
i just
aside from you like bad isn't it she
pooped in his bed apparently that's why
they call her amber turd she pooped in
his bed yeah that was like they have
they're having this huge lawsuit in
england
and one of the main
uh pieces of evidence is that she's [ __ ]
and pissed all over his house and so
they have text messages of of uh
of johnny depp texting with his friends
saying amber turd took a huge stinker in
my bed last night
it's literally a real text message
no way yeah
amber turd wow yeah that's kind of funny
that just goes to show you man that's
kind of funny dudes are just the same
like
exactly you can you can be in a giant
legal feud with your horrible ex-wife
and she defecates in your bed and you
come home and you're like paul andrew
turd just took a big stinker
yeah and it really just goes to [ __ ] it
doesn't matter how rich and famous and
successful you are oh we've got an
article on it this is the poop that
flushed johnny depp and amber heard's
marriage away there's a picture oh my
god oh no there's a photo this is news
to me yo
like that
new photo of feces that depth says heard
left in their bed
yo i don't think we could show feces
dude you guys gotta blur this out oh no
yo who dude you gotta give me a poop
warning it wasn't even it wasn't even a
very good turd yeah it looked like she
forced it out and just kind of wiped her
ass with the shoes
and it was her 30th birthday so do you
think she like got too [ __ ] up and did
it i think it was a spite turd from what
i understand
i've never been that angry
especially on your [ __ ] birthday
she was pissed
you literally
well cody
have we uh have we covered ground what
what have we learned here today
wiping stuff we talked a lot about poop
yeah bloodhound related things today
thank you for having me man yeah thanks
for coming on it's it's it's great to
have you i mean you're you're uh
a super funny dude super talented you
should be a motivational speaker you've
succeeded at everything in life
diver app developer
comedian
uh cyberbully
and uh
well if i start doing
motivational speeches yeah i'm up oh
yeah i want to be like
start yes no i'm not no i have nothing
to say
well you can hop on the end
hey guys thanks for watching
hope you learned a lot
yeah and always remember white from the
front right from the front that's the
word the path to success always begins
yeah well i'm very much looking forward
to that new video you got on deck
yeah i'm still i'm i hope people like it
i really do it's a little bit it's
different style i'm it's a little bit
you know corny almost i use like
background music and stuff like i really
try to treat it like um
you know kind of like a longer form
oh i narrate it so it kind of feels more
like a
movie sort of and so how long is your
film 22 minutes okay
that's an episode
yeah so
hopefully people like it
great man well i'd love to have you on
again
yeah i know thanks for having me
on your bowel movements and everything
yeah i'd love to talk more about poop
i'd actually love to have you on with
your girlfriend that'd be fun yeah no
we'd love to
i love you guys too say hi to hila for
me yeah well she's she uh is doing teddy
fresh stuff
oh okay got it she's a ceo now isn't it
business yeah she's businesses doesn't
sleep you know
no
well um cool be good god bless
and uh wish you well man thank you guys
appreciate it all right talk to you soon
take care bye
[Music]
[Music]
you